inside the sub has about as much room as
a minivan we only have one button that's
it it should be like an elevator you
know it shouldn't take a lot of skill
the Titan is the only five person sub in
the world it's also the only one with a
toilet well at least I had some weight
of that's one thing apparently the
CEO of Ocean Gate who's actually
operating the missing vessel didn't want
to hire any experienced 50 year old
white guys because they weren't
inspirational this can't be true I need
to hear this they typically
um have a gentlemen who were ex-military
submariners and they you'll see a whole
bunch of 50 year old white guys
um I wanted our team to be younger to be
inspirational do you know when I get on
a plane and there's an old dude flying
the plane I want experience when it
comes to my life being in someone else's
hands you know I don't care if you're
inspirational and you're the life and
soul of the party in fact if you're
really boring you probably take
seriously